couple de sécurité 400 euros javier
breton merci monsieur le président oui
je voudrais dire aux membres du
gouvernement et aux groupes socialistes
s'ils veulent faire un débat avec
françois fillon
il va y avoir la campagne présidentielle
pour le faire plutôt que de prendre en
otage des questions gouvernement de
manière scandaleuse
monsieur le premier ministre le stand de
la campagne viendra maintenant on est
autant des questions au gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre hier après
midi c'est le général a particulièrement
maltraité deux sujets pourtant cruciaux
pour le pays
l'éducation et la famille vous n'avait
évoqué que très rapidement l'éducation
en la réduisant à une approche purement
quantitative et budgétaire pourtant les
comparaisons internationales comme l'
enquête pisa publiées la semaine
dernière montrent bien que ce n'est pas
le niveau de dépenses qui compte mais la
bonne utilisation de ses moyens de plus
votre vision égalitariste de l'éducation
vous empêche de promouvoir les valeurs
de l'effort et du mérite et c'est cette
même vision égalitariste qui conduit au
grand bond en arrière de ces dernières
années comme la remise en cause de
l'aide personnalisée à l'école comme
l'affaiblissement des savoirs
fondamentaux ou comme la réforme des
rythmes scolaires ou du collège
toutes ces réformes ont été imposées
sans que les enseignants les élèves et
les parents d'élèves n'en comprennent la
cohérence ni l'objectif
votre discours de politique générale a
d'autre part fait totalement l'impasse
sur la politique familiale
il est vrai que la politique menée
depuis 2002 s'est traduite par un
matraquage fiscal des familles par la
remise en cause des fondements mêmes de
notre politique familiale qui faisait
pourtant consensus
depuis 1945 les résultats de cette
politique catastrophique ne se sont pas
fait attendre
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
la natalité est en recul dans notre pays
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
aviez hier l'occasion de renforcer
l'éducation à la famille de les replacer
au coeur de notre société comme étant
des priorités pourquoi ne l'avez vous
pas fait
la parole est à mme hemming najat
vallaud belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
xavier breton je me demande vraiment
dans quelle mesure vous croyez à ce que
vous êtes vous raconter vraiment dans
quelle mesure est ce que vous croyez
sincèrement boucle enquêtes pisa 2015
vient évaluer la politique actuelle du
gouvernement alors qu'elle porte sur des
enfants de 15 ans et donc sur la
scolarité qui a été la leur entre 2006
et 2013
expliquez moi en quoi cela vieille value
est notre politique
will enquêtes pisa cela était
suffisamment dit à donner de mauvais
résultats mais ces mauvais résultats ils
sont alliés très directement à la
politique qu à conduite à droite pendant
dix ans de suppression de la formation
des enseignants de suppression de 80
mille postes dans l'éducation nationale
et de sacrifice de l'éducation depuis
2012 et hell ocde qui vous intéressent
tant que ça l'a dit explicitement et je
le répète ses mots la politique conduite
depuis 2012 va dans le bon sens en
matière éducative
pourquoi car nous avons recréer des
postes
la meilleure façon de réduire les
effectifs par classe et donc
d'accompagner de façon plus
individualisé les élèves c'est d'avoir
le nombre de professeurs nécessaire car
nous avons recréé la formation des
enseignants ce qui les rend plus
efficace car nous avons remis en place
la préscolarisation des enfants de moins
de trois ans que nous avons installé
plus de maîtres queux de classe à
l'école primaire pour accompagner les
difficultés dès qu'elle apparaît ce que
nous avons fait la réforme du collège
pour améliorer les apprentissages
mais monsieur breton vous ne voulez pas
qu'on vous parle de votre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et pourtant et pourtant qu'y at-il
derrière son projet de suppression de
cinq cent mille postes de fonctionnaires
il y a plus de prêts scolarisation des
moins de trois ans il y a plus de
professeurs supplémentaires pourraient
les aider les élèves en difficulté il
n'y a plus d' aide
il ya le nouveau sacrifice pour
l'éducation nationale alors soyons
sérieux